i'm gonna tell you a fable a king
growing old has two daughters and wants
to partition his land he goes to his
counselor
and says
counselor i have four
pieces of land
and two daughters
and i want to
partition my land equally amongst my
daughters my surveyor
says that the land
masses i have
are of this shape
i have one triangular piece of land
and it has a square angle here
a right angle
says the counselor
you have a right angle triangle
ah a right angle triangle and then i
have a square piece of land whose edge
is the side of the longest side of my
triangle
and i have
another
whose edge
is the side of this side of the triangle
and a third
the side of this side of the triangle
the surveyor tells me they're all
squares the counselor says oh
no problem don't be one of these foolish
kings who gives away all your land keep
that triangular piece for yourself give
the largest
square
to one of your daughters and the two
small squares to the other daughter it
will be perfectly even that's easy says
the king and he's about to leave
but then says
counselor
i haven't told you anything about how
long
the sides of these squares are or the
shape of the triangle council says don't
worry what we have here is three squares
one triangle if the edges of these
pieces of land are doubled all the areas
get multiplied by four if they're
tripled all the areas get multiplied by
nine that's three squared if you
change
the all the lengths of your figures by
some factor the area is changed by the
square of the factor and so the
proportions are exactly the same
counselor says this is
called scaling and similarity if you
scale your figures in this way you get
similar figures scaling a length by some
factor scales the area by the square
wonderful says the king king walks away
but even before he leaves the room he
says but i didn't tell you what the
angles of the problem counselor says uh
that doesn't matter what we have here is
something called the pythagorean theorem
it doesn't matter what the angles are as
long as one of those angles is a right
angle king leaves
returns the next day
distraught and says
my surveyor tells me i don't have
squares
i have things that he
called blobs that is
i have a triangle a right angle triangle
i have three fields
each
landmass has one linear edge
the linear edge equal to the edge of the
corresponding edge of the triangle
and he also tells me
that my blobs are similar
if i scale any one of these blobs
appropriately
it will
become any of the others now what do i
do
asks the king apprehensively and the
counselor says no prob do exactly as
before you keep your triangle give the
larger
largest blob mass to one of your
daughters and the other two to the other
daughter and it'll be even steven the
king
is amazed he says
it doesn't matter
what
blobs
they are
as long as they're similar the counselor
says yes what do you call that says the
king oh i call that the blob pythagorean
theorem for every blob there's a blob
pythagorean theorem says the king
strange the counselor says yes and not
only that but um if you know the blob
pythagorean theorem for any blob you
know it for every bob the king says how
how how can that be well the counselor
says look
look at this you have three blobs here
imagine that there's what i'll call a
unit blob that is say a blob that's
similar to it
but its length is one
let us say the length of its straight
edge is one why then if the length of
this straight edge is uh c
and the length of this straight edge is
a
and the length of this straight edge is
b
then we know that whatever
area this blob has
let me call the area of that blob
capital a the area of the unit blob
the area of this blob
is this
square of the factor that one needs in
order to scale the unit blob to it so
the area will be c squared times a the
area of this will be a squared times a
and the area of this will be b squared
times a so if i prove to you that for
some blob with some area a this
large blob is the sum in area of the
areas of these two small ones what i
will have shown
is
c squared times a is equal to
a squared
times a
plus b squared times a
i'm canceling out the a's i have c
squared is equal to a squared times plus
b squared and so if you give me any
other blob i will get
exactly the same result so one blob
pythagorean theorem implies pythagorean
theorem for all blobs says the king and
he
leaves
sort of contented king comes in
day three
and says it's wonderful what you've told
me what you've explained to me but can
you show me
the blob pythagorean theorem for some
blob in which case i'll know it for all
the council says oh well for that you
have to draw me a right angle triangle
and the counselor says ah well so my job
then would be to
produce a blob with a linear side
uh
of length see
a blob with a linear side of length b
that blob being similar to the blob of
length c
and a blob
with length a similar to the other two
and then
i will have
to
show you that the area of the larger
largest of these blobs
is the sum of the area of the other two
blobs of the king says well
yes this might be um quite a chore the
counselor says
well
try this the counselor draws a single
line which meets
the large side
in a right angle
and then
steps back
and says
there you are where am i says the king
the blob whose linear edge is c
is the entire triangle the blob whose
linear edge is b is the triangle to the
right the blob whose linear edge is a is
the triangle to the left all these
triangles are right angle triangles
because one of their angles is a right
angle each of these triangles have
another angle in common for example
this large triangle
has this angle in common with this one
and it has this angle in common with
this one all three right angle triangles
are similar so those are my three blobs
and
to see that the sum of the two small
blobs is equal to large probe is
heaven
king says
ah
okay so now what's my moral
can you
guess but i don't know that kings ask a
lot of questions